sheffield just 25 years of age on a tula
home of tennessee
outside of nashville justice five and
five with a 4.91 era
and polanco to left that is a fair ball
into the corner and his knight will
start with an extra base head
polanco pulled the fastball foul then
hooked the next pitch into the corner
for a double
so polanco at second base nobody out
donaldson bats
line drive bases it to right towards the
corner that's going to land
on the grass and score polanco donaldson
on his way to second base and now the
throw gets away from godoy behind the
plate
and the twins take a one-nothing lead
chops it off the plate sheffield by the
shoelaces throws onto first
i'm going to bring up alex
and tyrolov will beat it out i'm kind of
surprised crawford
didn't give it a shot at third base so
two on one out
and now a big spot early for ryan
jeffers and the pitch is swinging a
smash up the middle base hit center
field
donaldson scores kiriloff down to second
the twins are hitting rockets off
sheffield early
and have a two-nothing lead in the
opening inning the 2-2 pitch swinging a
ground ball to short
jp's got it second there's one lungs
relayed at first and there's the double
play that sheffield's been looking for
and the side is retired 6-4-3 but the
twins get a couple
his numbers from his first three starts
in the big leagues but
i will tell you this he's going to throw
strikes early
and often and he's not going to walk
people
on that one playable it looks like
donaldson tracking it across the line
making the catch
to center celestino back now in
and along at that end with another out
through the air two down
got him up and in with the fastball then
sheffield's payoff
frankly going back a few strides and he
is underneath it
for round number one puts a piece
and gadoy holds on to it first strikeout
for sheffield tonight two gone
the 2-2 and that's exactly
what happens the slider gets salistino
josh donaldson
has left the ball game willian's hasta
dios in the third base
and donaldson with a bit of a grimace
and a
little bit of a slip and he kind of went
into second base
gingerly like he did after his first at
bat in milwaukee
by fastball on another full count and
it's ostadio with the cap on
making the cash two down
gone ball right side one op smash glove
by cino to the backhand side takes it to
the base for out number two
that was hard hit
hit the spot a call third strike and a
pair of one two three innings
long hold by sheffield the pitch swung
on popped up
playable right side france giving chase
so is long coming over to help from foul
territory going after
france makes the play here's the runner
at third tagging and he goes about
halfway and comes back then a ball gets
away from godoy
but he re retreats and keeps that runner
at third two in scoring position for
kirloff
malacca will score kirov is retired but
it's a three-nothing ball game
ground ball to the right side this is
scooped up by
jorge polanco as he feeds to know at
first base
high fast ball strike three
three perfect innings for bayley
ober trevor larnick is now
in left field the rise is at second base
and polanco's at short
so it is simmons who is out of the ball
game so a whole new left side of the
twins infield here's simmons last at bat
shaking his head from side to side so
i'm not sure what the issue is but there
appeared to be somewhat of a limp
twins three and the mariners nothing
bottom of the fourth
bailey over delivers swinging a line
drive past the third baseman off the
deal
into left field and i'm telling you jp
crawford
has just driven a groove right through
the left side of the infield for the
last
month and a half that's a great pitch
strength recall
[Applause]
there's one to the left field corner so
now he's gotten a hit to the left field
corner on all three of the man's pitches
sheffield really slowing the pace here's
the pitch and it's up and away
who is this guy oh my goodness williams
ostadia walked twice in the same game
runners on it first and second cruz
and a deep drive to lefty has teed off
and hit one into the second deck a
three-run
jolt doubling the twins lead home run
number 14
and now 34 runs batted in for the former
mariner
jeffers one for two tonight
there goes another one wow not to the
second deck but another home run for
jeffers
and it's seven to nothing these aren't
cheapies boy is his swing looks so much
better chris than it did
to start the season two outs france at
third
shed drives his right back where it came
from and with that the mariners are on
the board
[Applause]
and a rise fields the ground ball and
anager goes to third
one away one out haniger at third france
batting
stunned to center
donostino makes the catch hanniger
coming home
and he scores stanley
the man that santiago just struck out
backhand by crawford
two gone
this is into the shift and larnick
is out number three
there's a fastball 97 for a called third
strike
ground ball hit right two the second
baseman arrived
celestino glides in to make the catch
and rogers has a one two three
eighth inning
[Applause]
in a row first pitch popped up and alpha
pumps his fist
twice didn't get a save but he had a one
two three ninth inning
and the twins will head out of seattle
with a nice
convincing front to back win